Hello, this is Jyn from Next Level
Commander and today we have a Final
Fantasy Commander deck, the Collector's
Edition. The cards in here are beautiful
once I open it. I think you'll
understand why I bought the collector's
edition. But today, we are not just
opening the cards. We are taking a look
at the deck and evaluating the cards.
And we're looking to make some cuts and
replacements to level up this deck.
Because in Magic Commander, there are
actually five brackets now that
represent different power levels. And
usually a pre-cond like this is bracket
two. But through cutting some cards that
are less synergistic and replacing them
with more powerful, more synergistic
cards, we're looking to upgrade this to
a bracket three so that we can have more
fun playing it honestly and face
different, more varied opponents. So
let's take a look. Let's begin.
How do you open this?
Okay, we've got a deck box and uh this
rack here with
the deck.
What is this? This is the
collector booster sample pack. We will
open this in the end. But we also have
some like emblems, tokens kind of thing
and how to play.
Sweet. Okay, let's go straight to the
deck itself.
The first card we have is Terra, Hero of
Hope. At the beginning of combat on your
turn, mill two cards, Terra against
flying until the end of turn. Whenever
Terra deals combat damage to a player,
you may pay two when you do a return
target creature card with power three or
less from your graveyard to the
battlefield. Tapped. You can see the
treatment. Oh, this is super nice. And
this card is kind of a it reminds me of
Alicia right from a while ago. But this
is a graveyard deck that is kind of
aggressive, right? It wants to attack
and uh yeah, it brings back some of the
bigger cards from your graveyard because
this also says we're power three, not
CMC. So maybe we can cheat this with
cards that are high CMC and low power.
But we'll have to see what else this
deck does. But right now it seems like
again a gray centric deck that wants to
attack that wants to be more aggressive
and that also fits the color the color
combo.
All right. So now Celeste rune knight.
When Celis enters discard any number of
cards then draw that many cards plus
one.
Whenever one or more other creatures you
control enter, if one or more of them
entered from the graveyard or was cast
from a graveyard, put a plus one plus
encounter on each creature you control.
Okay, this fits. I mean, these two
legendaries fit really well together.
And yeah, this is like Celest is like an
enabler for Terra and at the same time
it's also pumping our board. So great
for aggressive
the aggressive game plan.
Coin of Fate. When this artifact enters,
surveil one. Uh, exile two creature
cards from your commander. Sacrifice
this artifact. An opponent chooses one
of the exile cards. Put that card on the
bottom. Then return the other to the
battlefield tapped and you become the
monarch. Okay, this card has got three
abilities. Neither of them are really
powerful. I guess the the returning a
creature one is decent because it can be
activated at instant speed, but also
making monarch. All of these are cards
that we want are effects that we want in
this deck. So, I kind of like this card.
And again, I'll try to I try not to cut
cards if possible just because I imagine
a lot of people want to keep the Final
Fantasy theme together, but for now,
this card is fine. Can Vengeful Samurai,
seven mana. This spell cost one less for
each creature card in your graveyard.
Whenever one or more creature cards
leave your graveyard, it gets plus one
plus one counter. Uh this is the kind of
card that does nothing except it's big
right it will be cheap and is kind of
big can attack for say 5577 double
strike. So later if we see that this
deck is more aggressive more beatd down
sure this can go in but if we're looking
for more graveyard synergy or more value
then will be cut.
So for now we're going to make a maybe
pile. Actually the maybe pile is for
cards that are we're not so sure about
keeping. So, let's flip them back like
this. Okay, next up, General Leo
Christophé. When General Leo enters,
return up to one target creature card
with mana value three or less from your
graveyard to the battlefield. Then, put
a plus one plus one counter on it for
each creature you control. So, this is a
three three at least, and it's like a
mini Sun Titan effect, returning three
CMC creatures. We'll see how many three
CMC creatures we have, but I imagine
there's a bunch. I mean, our commander
is three CMC if I'm not mistaken and
yeah, this is a decent effect. Again,
not as good as Sun Titan, but this
creature has the potential to go pretty
big, right? To be a 5577. So, I think
it's a keep for now.
Especiite
each uh exile each opponent's graveyard.
When you do, choose up to one target
creature card. exile this way, create a
token that's a copy of this card, except
it's an artifact and it loses all other
card types. So, it's a really cool
instant. I would I would play this in a
lot of decks, but for this deck, again,
this deck, we're not focusing on
stealing from our opponents, I believe.
So, if this was able to make something,
steal something from our own graveyard
without exiling it, I'd play it. But
right now, again, it's a good card, but
I don't think it's got enough synergy.
So, I will set this aside in the maybe
pile for now. The Falcon Airship
Restored. I opened a lot of these
yesterday in a collector in the
collector's booster box, but it's a
great card, right? When it deals damage,
you may sacrifice it. You can return
then you can reanimate a creature. And
this is only three mana, so it's pretty
good value if you hit someone. And also,
you can spend five mana to return this
card from your graveyard to the
battlefield tapped. So, if you mill this
and you just activate it this ability,
it's pure value. And crew two is
reasonable. So again, vehicles are kind
of I I feel kind of out of place in this
deck, but but the abilities do synergize
well. So we'll keep this for now.
Interceptor, shadows, hound, menace.
Assassins you control have menace.
Whenever you attack with one or more
legendary creatures, you may pay two and
a black when you do. If you do, return
this card from your graveyard to the
battlefield, tapped and attacking.
Uh again, this is like the airship where
you can mill this and you can bring it
back, but it's what it gives assassin's
menace and it's a menace 43 because this
is kind of an aggressive card, but at
the same time, it feels like a almost an
aristocrat kind of card, which I'm not
sure this deck is doing. And yeah, you
can return this tapped and attacking.
How many assassins do we have? Do we
have a bunch of assassins that this
enables?
Not really.
I think we'll have to see on this one.
We'll put this on in the maybe pile.
Rejoin the fight. Mill three cards.
Then, starting with the next opponent in
turn order. Each opponent chooses a
creature card in your graveyard that has
hasn't been chosen. Return each card
chosen this way to the battlefield under
your control. So you mill three and then
you you return in a four-player game the
three worst creatures in your graveyard
for six mana. I think it's reasonable.
It's not the best reimate spell, but it
does fit in this deck and it's it can be
pretty good. So yeah, we'll give it a
pass. Shadow Mysterious Assassin death
touch 33. Whenever it deals combat
damage to a player, you may sacrifice
another nonland permanent. If you do,
draw two cards and each opponent loses
life equal to the mana value of the
sacrificed permanent.
Again, I'm not sure this deck is a kind
of an aristocrat deck. It can work
because again, your commander is
reanimating from the graveyard. But what
are we going to sacrifice if we can make
a bunch of tokens? Sure. If we can have
a lot of creatures that are that are
like bloodgast creatures and
interceptor.
Oh yeah, this is his dog. I just
realized. But interceptor, the cost is
not cheap, right, to return it. So, I'm
not so sure here.
I'll put shadow again in the maybe pile.
If we turn out to be more tokeny, more
aristocraty, then this will come back
in. Seigrid framed a famed swordsman.
Four mana menace. When he enters mill
three cards, then put X plus one
counters on Seek Fred where X is twice
the number of creature cards in your
graveyard. Now, milling is nice because
it enables our commander. And how big
can this get? It can get pretty big big
dong. So where do we put the other big
dong? In the maybe pile. So yeah, we'll
also put him in the maybe pile. If we
are aggressive. If we are about the
beatdown, then he will go in the deck.
Gao Feral Youth. Whenever Gal attacks,
put a plus one counter on it. At the
beginning of each end step, if a card
left your graveyard this turn, Gal deals
damage equal to its power to each
opponent.
So, it's fairly aggressive, but also
synergizes with our commander and our
regular strategy. So, this is the kind
of card that we want, we want to keep.
Go, mysterious mime. At the beginning of
combat on your turn, you may have go
become copy of another target creature
you control until the end of turn,
except it name is Go. If you do, go and
that creature each get plus two plus O
and gain haste until the end of turn and
attack this turn if able. It's nice cuz
you can copy your commander, copy a
legendary, and pump each other. And this
card is quite aggressive, but it has no
graveyard synergy.
Yeah, it's just an aggressive card that
gives haste. I I think it's just on on
power alone this goes in because it's a
really powerful card. Unlike cards like,
you know, seek freak where if we're our
deck is not doing it, this card is not
really justifiable on power alone.
Meanwhile, go is aggressive and it's
again getting double triggers from our
commander just feels amazing. And this
is, I think, maybe one of the best cards
we've seen so far. So, we'll keep it in
for now. Seven. Sabin seven master of
monk
five mana 43 double strike. Wow. Blitz
discard a card. You may cast this card
from your graveyard using its blitz
ability. So what blitz does is you can
cast it. It will get haste, but the
problem is it you will only last for a
turn and then die. But when it dies, you
draw a card. So it's kind of kind of a
not sure how to say it, but you get to
use it for one turn, cash it in, and get
some value. Uh let's see. We can
blizzard from the graveyard by
discarding a card. Yeah, that's just
excellent synergy because again, casting
from graveyard is good. Being able to
discard something you want to discard to
reanimate later is excellent. And it's
also a really aggressive body. So
definitely a yes. Snort. Each player may
discard their hand and draw five cards.
Then snort deals five damage to each
opponent who did this. Um wheels are
good. They're kind of risky, especially
when it's a May where your opponents
can. This is helping your opponents a
lot. Dealing five damage to each
opponent is decent. Four mana. And this
card, I think, is solid and it really
enables our deck. And the idea is that
it is symmetrical, but we want to break
the symmetry of the discarding draw and
also is able to be cast from the
graveyard. So, this is the card I would
put into the deck and try it to see if
we are helping our opponents more than
ourselves. But for now, we'll keep it.
Straggle and realm. Let's see.
Three mana, one three
cost three to activate. Target opponent
exiles cards from the top of their
library until they exile instant sorcery
or a creature card. You may cast this
card without paying its mana cost. If
you cast a creature spell this way, it
gains haste and sacrifice it at the
beginning of endstep
and activate only a sorcery. So this
card doesn't do anything with our deck.
Yeah, I understand with these decks you
have to have a theme, but also at the
same time there's each deck is
representing a Final Fantasy game,
right? So for a lot of the characters,
you need to do top down design and
between top down design and having a syn
having a theme and synergy, it's
difficult to balance. So this is a case
where just a random good stuff card. So
I would cut it probably.
Next up, summon Esper Val Garmand.
four mana 33 flying haste. That's pretty
aggressive, but exile an instant or
sorcery card from your graveyard from
each graveyard. Then you can add red for
each lore counter on this saga and you
may cast instant or sorcery
uh cards exalt with the saga and you can
use the mana from this
h
I mean it kind of works with our deck
the graveyard synergy but you need like
when this comes down you need to have
decent instant and sorcerers in our in
our graveyard. We can't really depend on
our opponents having it right. So, I
will say maybe for this. It's such a
good card, but again, is it for this
deck? We'll have to see. Um, Raging
Yeti. Oh boy, this is cool. Six man of
66. Trample at the beginning of combat
on your turn. Choose one at random.
Other creatures get plus three and
trample. That's really good. Discard
your hand and draw four cards. That's
pretty good. And it deals five damage to
any target. Yeah, all three modes are
pretty good except maybe the number two
when you don't want to discard your hand
and it it does that. But that's kind of
the fun with the chaos. And again, all
abilities are synergistic with what
we're trying to do. So
yeah, I want to keep this in for now.
Benon, the returner's leader. This one
we also opened yesterday. Once during
each trophy returns, you may cast a
creature spell from among the cards in
your graveyard that were put there this
turn from anywhere other than the
battlefield this turn. And whenever you
attack, you can pay one to loot to
discard a card and draw a card. Yeah,
two mana. It's a bit aggressive. The
cost is aggressive, but not the body.
And although it's whenever you attack,
so any creature, he doesn't have to
attack. and being able to cast
something. It's like paying one to loot
and then it's basically paying one to
draw a card every turn, right?
It's cool. It's synergistic, but I feel
like it's not quite impactful for for
what we want to do. It's too slow. And
yeah, the ability when you drop this on
turn two, it's not really an aggressive
start, is it?
you don't really want to pay the one
extra because you want to cast a three
drop and you're not pressuring anyone's
lab total with a one three body. So, I
don't think this card does enough for
our deck. And we got tons of mill
cycling discard. So, I don't think we
need this. Maybe
Edgar Master Machinist.
Once each turn you uh during each of
your turns, you may cast an artifact
spell from your graveyard. If you cast a
spell this way, that artifact enters
tapped. When Edgar attacks, it gives
plus X plus O where X is the greatest
mana value among artifacts you control.
We are not an artifact deck as far as I
can tell. We got one artifact. That's
decent, but
are we going to be able to get one
artifact a turn to cast? We will have to
see. I doubt it. This is another one of
those, I'm guessing, top down designs
that they try to make it fit into this
deck. Uh, but in practice, it's not it's
not working too well from what I can
tell. So maybe Kefka, Dancing Mad.
During your turn, Kfka has
indestructible. Oh, this is seven mana.
Wow. At the beginning of your end step,
exile a card at random from each
opponent's graveyard. You may cast any
number of spells from among the cards
exiled this way without paying their
mana costs. Then each player who owns a
spell you cast this way loses life equal
to it mana value.
Again, this is working with your
opponent's graveyards.
You can cast spells from your graveyards
and then they lose life. This is such a
cool card. I want to play it, but again,
we want to do synergy first. Again,
we'll see how many cards we're cutting.
This might again, if I have to keep a
card that is not so synergistic with the
deck, this will be it, but we'll have to
see. Lock, treasure hunter. Lock can't
be blocked by creatures with greater
power. Whenever lock attacks, each
player mills a card. If a land card was
mailed this way, create a treasure token
until the end of turn. You can cast a
spell from among those cards. So this
guy is thief
and very easy to it's really easy for
you to get through to an opponent with
this evasion and each player milling
one. If you mill a land get a treasure
and then you can cast the cards you
steal.
Not entirely synergistic but it's got
the stats to reanimate that we can
reanimate with our commander and it does
the milling and the treasure is nice.
So, I'd say overall this card is decent.
Yeah. Again, we are prioritizing lower
cost and more aggressive creatures
because that's what our deck seems to be
doing. So, it's in
Mog Mughal Warrior
three mana lifelink dance. At the
beginning of your end step, each player
may discard a card. Each player who
discarded a card this way draws a card.
If a creature card was discarded this
way, you create a one two white mug
creature token. Then if another creature
card was discarded this way, put a plus
one counter on each you control.
So you can discard the creature because
most likely your opponents will be
discarding none creatures. So the
ceiling of this card is that every turn
you play this right at the end step
you're creating a token and they are
what? How big are they? They are both
waiter
on each. Yeah. So they are both two
threes. So three mana you get two two
three. uh two three lifelinks and you
get to loot. I think that's aggressive
enough because it will continue to grow
the turn after and the turn after you
will have a uh two two threes and then
next turn you will have two three fours
and a two three and meanwhile you're
fueling your graveyard. You're helping
your opponents a little bit too but I
think it's decent.
Setser wandering gambler.
When sets interest, create the
blackjack, a legendary three colorless
vehicle.
Okay. Whenever a vehicle you control
deals combat to damage, flip a coin.
Whenever you win the flip, win a flip,
create two tapped treasure tokens. Yeah,
this is a cool card, but not for this
deck. It's not made for this deck.
Holy, what is this? The waring triad.
Flying treble haste. Three mana, five
five. As long as there are fewer than
eight cards in your graveyard, the
waring triad isn't a creature.
Tap to mill a card. Target player as one
mana of any color. Wow, this is this
like the best mana rock you can make for
this deck. Yeah, this is sweet. It's
just a three mana mana rock and yeah,
you can mill yourself and in the end you
have a decent payoff. Yeah, I like this
a lot. I like this a lot.
Oh, now reprints. Sun Titan.
What
this is? Wow, this art. I wonder what
character this is. But yeah, Sun Titan.
I mean, it's a staple from 15 years ago,
but even now, I think it's pretty good.
I think it's good enough just because
when you mill yourself, you can get
lands, you can get small creatures, and
Sun Titan will will be a constant stream
of value for your deck. And it's just so
cool. It's hard to say no to this. Yeah,
we're putting this in tragic arrogance.
That's a reprint. an excellent board
wipe.
And this card, I think
I think you play it even today. There is
no board wipe like this where you can
keep something, your opponents can keep
something, but chances are what you let
them keep is garbage. The key here is
that you are the one picking what they
keep. So, as a board wipe, I think this
is solid. Arc faint of depravity. This
is a Yeah, this is I think they keep
trying to put this into pre-context, but
this card is just not good. I think you
have a five mana 54 demon and basically
your opponents can keep two creatures
and then sacrifice the rest like who who
needs more than two creatures usually
right if you're going wide sure but for
most opponents two key creatures is what
they need and sacrificing the worst one
is not it's not that bad and there are
there are way better effects if you want
to clear the board right so I think arc
fiend is like the first card I cut from
each precon which is unfortunate because
the art is sick but we'll continue.
Whoops. This is a maybe
reanimate. Oh, reanimate reprint.
Yeah, this is one of the best
reanimation spells in the game and
definitely fits our deck.
Rise of the Dark Realms. This is a win
condition. Yeah, one of the better win
conditions.
Just gets all creatures from all
graveyards. you're not milling your
opponents too much. So, this is not as
good, but it's still really powerful if
you get to that nine mana. And again, if
you're playing graveyard decks, you got
to play the payoffs, right? This is like
one of the payoffs.
So, Poke Crop Primordial.
Yeah, this card is so powerful, but
again, you are stealing from your
opponents. Sure, as the game goes
naturally, you can steal things, but
there's not much synergy with this card.
again can't be reanimated with our
commander and
yeah it's again such a cool card you can
put this in another deck but for this
deck I don't think so
combustible gear hulk
when it enters you can an opponent can
let you draw otherwise you mill yourself
and boom them for damage now imagine
this is the punisher effect imagine if
your opponents just always let you do
the damage I don't think this is very
good and generally I think opponents
would because your deck doesn't have a
massive CMC. So on average, you're
dealing probably six or six or to eight
damage from the mill and you mill
yourself for three. And for this cost, I
don't think it's worth it.
If your play group is more friendly and
less, you know, there tech is strictly
speaking playing the game kind of
loosely. They'll let you draw. This is
decent. But even then, six mana, draw
three. I think we can do better. So
maybe
flare of the hatebound. Whenever this
creature or another creature enters from
a graveyard, it deals damage equal to
its power to any target. Yeah, this is
another one of the chaos for this deck.
It's pretty much perfect in here except
it's got four power unfortunately, but
yeah, it's a great card. It's got
undying, so it will come back when it
dies.
Rune Grinder. When this creature dies,
each player may discard their hand and
draw seven cards mountain cycling. I
would keep this in just for the mountain
cycling because this uh wheel effect
once again is a may and you don't want
to help your opponents with this.
Usually, I find wheels help your
opponents a lot. But yeah, with mount
cycling, you can just situationally you
decide, okay, I don't want this in my
hand. I don't want to cast it this game.
I can just cycle it. So, it's decent.
Redevil. Redevil. This is serviceable is
what I can say. Destroy target artifact
creature or planes walker. But honestly
in Mardu you have much much better
removals. Yeah, just destroying
something. And this color cost is not
it's fairly color intensive, right? It's
not cheap. So we'll put this in the mini
board to see if we have room to upgrade
the removal. If we do, we will.
Next. Allegiance to Ashes. Exile target
nonline permanent and opponent controls
and all tokens that player controls with
the same name.
If this was an instant, this would be
top top removal. But as a sorcery, I
don't think this is good enough because
once again, you are in the best colors
for removals. Even like a path to exile,
I think you're better off with. But
something like, you know, merciless
eviction, a merciless, what's it called?
Anguish on making. My apologies. Anguish
on making would just so much better than
this. So, probably not. Priests of fell
rights.
Pay three life, sacrifice it. Oh, this
is a two mana reanimation spell. It's a
bit slow and it costs life, but again,
two mana to reanimate something is
excellent value. And also, the Unear is
great. Five mana, you can get another
one immediately. Yeah, this is great for
our deck. Ruinous Ultimatum. Wow, that's
cool. Yeah, this is uh one of the payoff
cards for playing Mardu. It's one of the
staples.
Arguably one of the best board wives you
can play. Yeah. Destroy everything your
opponent's control and keep all your
stuff.
This one stays in. Key to the city.
Discard a card. You can give something
unblockable and then when it untaps, you
can pay to to draw a card. It's a bit
slow, but it does have great synergy
with the deck cuz sometimes you don't
even need to draw the card. Just you
just want to discard outlet and at the
same time your commander is not huge,
right? How big is our commander? Let's
see. Our commander Terra is a three-
three
does get flying though. So the evasion
I'm not sure we need the evasion anymore
then because what's the chance of each
opponent having a flying blocker
but again we are kind of aggressive. We
want to attack. So this card draw
unblockable might be good enough. I'll
put this in the deck and see and see how
it performs.
All right, next up, Solemn. Whoops. So
similacrim.
It's uh an old staple, but I think it's
still good enough, especially in Mardu
when you don't have green. And just
bring this back with our commander is
excellent value. Yeah, it's all I want
to do. Even though I should be
aggressive and attacking, but I just
want to recur this card. Yeah, it's like
the for those of you not familiar, this
is like the OG value card.
Yeah. And to this day, it's still it's
so nice to see in your in your hand.
Are we on to lands already? I guess we
are. Battlefield Forge. It's a decent
land.
Cliptop retreat. Yeah, I think a lot of
the lands they're including are just
really good compared to especially the
precons from the early days. Now,
nowadays, they've printed and reprinted
so many of these lands that they are not
that expensive that they won't hurt
their reprint equity so much. So they
are more generous with it. And the
precon land base is honestly decent. I
wouldn't change it too much. I don't
feel the need to do that. Dragon skull
summit. Yeah. Exotic Orchard.
Oh wow. Filter lens too. Nice. For
boating runes, Furycom, snarl. Yeah,
these are all lands I would play
anyways. At least in two-color decks. In
three color, there are some upgrades,
but I wouldn't feel bad playing these
lands. High market, excellent choice.
Isolated Chapo rugged prairie. Yeah, so
far the lands look great. Uh, shadow
blood ridge
shine, shadow snarl, smoldering marsh.
Yo, the colors in this deck is solid.
Okay, but why do we have more nonlands?
What is happening? Did I mess up the
sorting? Maybe I did, but it's okay.
We'll keep going. Phoenix down one
uh one color, one white for exoit. You
can return a four mana card from your
graveyard to the battlefield tapped or
exile skeleton spirit zombie. So this
part is not that relevant. It'll be
hilarious if it's relevant, but I
playing a card just for that effect. I
don't think is good enough. I mean, just
compare this to reanimate, right? So
maybe laughing mad as an additional cost
to cast this. Discard a card,
draw two cards, flashback.
Yeah, that's pretty good value.
Excellent enabler.
Angel of ruins.
It's got plane cycling. When it enters,
exops two target artifacts or
enchantments.
We don't have a lot of big reanimation
effects. So, if we cycle this, this is b
basically stay in the graveyard. But the
body I think is quite relevant being
able to again this is seven mana 57 is
excellent excellent rate and early game
again if you seven mana is too far out
of reach you can just cycle it for a
land. So this is yeah I think overall an
excellent card
palace Jailer. When this creature enters
you become the monarch when this
creature enters exile target creature
until you lose monarch until an opponent
becomes the monarch. This is great in
legacy but not in commander just because
it's much easier for them to take
monarch for you from you than to remove
a creature. So this is worse than like
an oblivion oblivion ring effect.
And monarch is nice. We like monarch but
there are way better cards for giving
monarch. So we will not include this
morbid opportunist. Whenever one or more
other creatures die, draw a card.
We are not killing our own creatures. At
least not with what we've seen so far.
We saw one card that can sacrifice, but
aside from that, we're not really
triggering this ourselves. So, we have
to rely on on our opponents triggering
this. I don't think that's super
super
I don't think that's too reliable.
I don't think we can bank on that. So, I
This card probably doesn't do enough in
this deck. Nice whisper. Just a simple
basic draw spell that goes in for sure.
Pitilus thunder. Whenever another
creature you control dies, create a
treasure token. Again, we are not
killing our own creatures. But I mean,
seeing those two cards, I may be wrong.
If later we see some aristo more
Aristocrat pieces, then we will we will
adjust. But for now, it's not in the
deck. Stitch together. This is not the
best reanimation spell, but but it's
decent. I guess serviceable.
And uh getting threshold should be
fairly easy in this deck. So we'll keep
it in for now. Stitcher supplier. All
this card does is mill.
I don't think it's enough. I want my
cards to, you know, mill and also do
other things, not just a one mana one
one that jump blocks once. Maybe anger.
Yeah, this is like a staple in the
aggressive graveyard deck. I mean, this
the perfect card. Never cast this unless
I mean you'll feel sad if you cast this.
Generally, you want to discard it or
mill this into the graveyard and then
your entire team is just that much
stronger, that much more aggressive. Big
score, discard one, draw two, create two
treasures. Great card.
Yeah, not much to say. Crackling Doom.
This is a pretty good removal, right?
Each opponent sacrifices their biggest
creature compared to what we saw, the
ones we cut earlier, right? You can see
why this is better. and two damage to
each opponent. Why not? Mortify.
Not the best removal, but I think
serviceable.
Yeah, because again, instant speed is
just huge. And creature enchantment, no
BS.
All right, next up, we have some ramp.
Arcane Signate, not much to say.
Commander Sphere seems good. Meteor
Golem,
seven mana when it enters. destroy
something. It's a three- three, so it
works with our commander. I feel really
good to bring this back over and over.
We don't have a bunch of sacrifice
effects, but it looks like we might have
to add some. So, the meteor golem will
we'll keep it in for now.
Yeah, just because we need more removals
and something that synergistic that's
synergistic with our commander and can
be done over and over. I think is it's
worth trying at least. Milikin two mana
one one add colorless mill a card. Is
this good? I'm not sure how to evaluate
this card. I don't think it's excellent,
but getting this on on turn two is
pretty nice. You pretty much you enable
your entire strategy or you can mill
mill add some mana. So it'll be really
nice to see this in the opening hand. So
I'll keep it in for now, but I I suspect
this will be one of the first cuts when
I find something better.
Mindstone. Cool card. Sar ring.
This is Wow. What is this ring? I want
to Is it a Magisite?
Yeah. I wish I play more Final Fantasy
again so I can appreciate these cards
more. Sweetful boots. Beautiful.
Talisman. Excellent. Talisman. Only two
of them. Really?
We'll see. Wait for his bobble. That's a
lot of ramp. Honestly, how many pieces
of ramp do we have? Let's take a look.
Two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10 pieces of ramp.
Okay,
it's fine. Ash barons. Okay, more lands.
Demolition field. It can destroy a
special land. It's not the best land
destruction effect, but again, we need
it. You know, we Well, people are
playing crazier and crazier lands
nowadays, and we need something like
this keep to keep them in check.
Evolving wilds, I don't think we play.
Although
filling our graveyard, we do have some
payoff like Sun Titan for example.
Okay, we play it. Yeah, there's enough
synergy and no way they would include
the fetches in here. And we're not going
to uh recommend fetches in our upgrade
guide. We'll try to have a budget. So
now we have some lands that we might
cut. Geothermal bog. This land interest
tapped. It's got basic land type, but
it's just not good enough.
Like I would cut this, but right now I
want to save our upgrade slots slots for
nonlands. So for now, we'll keep it in.
But honestly,
let's see how many basics there are. I
think replacing these with basics would
just be better because you don't have
that many basics. But you're probably
better off with basics compared to these
cards.
Nomad outpost again tapped, but it's
three different colors. So this I will
I'll let it go. But entering tab making
two mana and having even though it has
basic land types but it's not really
relevant in this deck. So yeah this I
think I will keep
path of ancestry.
Do we have a lot of tribal stuff?
Let's take a look.
Human human vehicle human wizard human.
Okay I think that's reasonable. Yeah
mugo god.
I think that's reasonable. Okay, even
just scrying once from your commander is
kind of okay, but if you scry twice, I
think it's it's paid for itself. So,
also it makes any color. Yeah,
definitely. Rogues Passage, expensive,
unblockable, but it's still unblockable
on a land. So, I'd say yes. Sacred
Peaks. Yeah, you know how I feel about
this.
Um, Command Tower, yes. And then basics.
One, two, three. These basics are These
are nice. Wow.
Yeah. See, at the same time now I I
don't want to add more basics just
because I want to keep them this art. If
we add basics, we'll have to add
something different. Or if you go really
deep, you go buy some basics. Some of
these basics and add them in. But yeah,
this is nice. Wow. The blackjack. Okay.
Now we're on to tokens. Coffee. Coffee.
Coffee. Treasure. Treasure. Okay. And
that is the deck. Let's take a look at
how many cards we put into the maybe
pile. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 21 cards. Just over
20. But there are a few cards in here
that I actually after seeing the whole
deck I want to return. Now the first
card is
let's see
secret. Yes, because we are a big dumb
beat down deck. It is confirmed and this
is a big dump big dump beater that knows
our that fills our graveyard. So for
sure shadow still no buts can
again doesn't enable our strategy but
does synergize with it gets cheaper. you
know, dropping this for say three or
four mana and having it be,
I don't know, easily a 55 I think is
reasonable, solid, can win games for
you.
And for everything else, we'll take a
closer look after
I sleeve everything.
Okay, this is where we look at some
cards we add. So, we ended up cutting 19
cards here. We will add in 19 cards, but
before that, I remember this. I forgot
to open it earlier, so I will open it
now. Collectors sample pack. Let's see
what's in here.
Nice. An ad card.
Uh, okay. We got summon Exion.
Oh, this is cool. And High Digger. High
digger. This is okay. Cool cards. But
for now, we're going to focus on the
deck itself. I've separated the cards by
function. Uh, we have lens removals and
that. So, lens, starting with lens, we
got 37. Yeah, I think this is fine.
Maybe a little bit low, but our deck is
also pretty low curve, so it's okay. I
don't like the tapped ones. Where are
they? These ones, but we'll keep them in
for now because we want to focus on the
change on nonland cards because those
changes will be a little bit more
impactful. So, for nonland cards, we're
starting with this pile, which is the
cards that help us fill our graveyard.
We have 10 pieces here. I think that's
solid. We do want more, but the cards in
here are pretty good. Yes, because this
is kind of the main strategy of the
deck. nothing like this pile. The pile
that recurs won't do anything without
this pile. So, we want to add more here.
And the recursion pile, fortunately, our
commander does a bit of both. It kind of
fills our graveyard and does recursion.
So, this can this one card can count
towards both piles and multiple cards
because again, it's our commander and
we've got 1, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 10 cards
here as well. 10 cards that bring stuff
back from graveyard or does recursion.
Yeah. Next up, spot removals. Spot
removals and board wipe. Actually, uh,
four spot removals and two board wipes.
I think this number is a little bit low.
I will add two to each. Yeah, two to
each. And once we're done with that,
this is ramp. I miscounted earlier. We
have nine pieces of ramp, which I think
is more than enough for this deck.
Again, our curve is not that high. So,
nine pieces of ramp and also random good
stuff. So, beat beers payoff. uh just
really good creatures with two power and
yeah big dudes and some draw spell.
So now we will add 19 cards to the deck.
So starting off we'll start with the
recursion cards. So first of all, living
death. This is like the ultimate
ultimate card to pay off for graveyard
decks. uh when you need a board wipe
especially you can just pull this off
and bring back five to seven creatures
from your vyard and it's so much value.
I mean it can backfire you won't always
want to cast it but when you do it's so
good. Next up karmic guide. Now this is
excellent because it is two power and it
can bring back any of the larger
creatures. So with your commander, your
commander can bring back Terra can bring
back Karma Guide and Karma Guide can
bring back anything and it's got an echo
cost which means it will sacrifice
itself at the end of the next turn it
comes in and if you don't pay the echo
cost but that's actually an upside
because being able to dump itself into
the graveyard isn't something that a lot
of creatures have. And we don't have a
ton of sack colors in this deck. We're
not going to that direction. So Karma
Guide is actually perfect for this deck.
U yeah goes into this pile here.
these two and Marshall's Anthem. This is
one of the most efficient reanimator
spells
of you pay four for an Anthem and after
that every two mana gets you a creature
back. No finality counters, no no catch,
just you just give them back and they
all get plus one plus one. So all these
abilities are extremely relevant to our
strategy to our game plan. So this goes
in and Alicia the original Terara kind
of the OG terra where is has a very
similar ability but only brings back two
power creatures. Now we in this deck I
counted we have about 12 I think 12 to
13 two power creatures so it's more than
enough uh to satisfy Alicia and yeah
also you can bring back Alicia with our
commander to start kind of a chain which
is cool. All right. So, these are the
Now we have the pile for bringing stuff
back from the graveyard. Now, take a
look at the enablers or the discard.
Starting off, we have
faithless looting. This is the classic,
one of the most efficient discard
spells, uh, loot spells. It will get
what you want in the graveyard dumped.
And also, flashback. You can also dump
this and just cast it from the graveyard
without costing a card. And next up,
this one is a little bit strange. This
brass is tunnel grinder.
It's a weird transforming artifact,
legendary artifact. But look at the
ability though. When it enters, you can
discard any number of cards and draw
that many cards plus one. So, it even
replaces itself. And you can dump
whatever you don't need and replace them
with new cards. And the second ability
is also decent. It says at the beginning
of your end step, if you descended this
turn, put a bore counter onto it. And
when there are three board counters, you
can flip it into a land. Well, first of
all, triggering this is super easy in
our deck with even just our commander,
right? With just our commander, it's
really easy to trigger the sand. So, in
two, three, in three turns, actually,
this will flip and it ramps you. And
also, the land is quite powerful, even
though it has no synergy with the deck,
but it's just a really good value.
Whenever you cast a permanent spell, uh,
using this mana, this red mana, you get
to discover X, where X is that spell's
value. So, one spell becomes two spells
basically. Yeah, enabler and later value
payoff. Next up is Doom Whisperer. I
don't think there's any questions about
this. This is one of the best enablers
for any graveyard strategy because the
pay two life serial. You can just use it
unlimited number of times. Now, be
careful with your life total. We don't
have a ton of life gain in this deck. I
added a little bit, but this card is
just too good to pass up. Just be
careful. Don't use it too aggressively
because you're not really a combo deck.
And so, we have to maintain a life total
while we beat down our opponents. And
next, Buried Alive. Not much to say
about this one. You straight up search
for the three best targets into your and
dump them into your graveyard and your
commander will can reanimate them
immediately.
Yeah, just pure value. Next up, let's
take a quick look at some removals and
board wipes. So, the removals I added
are number one, a cursed Whoops. A
cursed marauder. This is the premium
like the top flashbang marauder effect
now because it's two mana and it has to
be none token. So, this is just an
upgrade. And for two mana, you can
continue to loot this if your opponents
are low on creatures. For example, if
they're a Voltron deck or something
that's creature light, for example,
Spellinger with their just their
commander, you can lock them. Whoops.
You can lock them out with this and your
commander. And I think for a deck like
this, we need we need such an effect.
Maybe even more if you find them to be
really really powerful in your meta and
removal. Next up is generous gift. This
is just uh yeah, one of the best rules
out there. Uh again, instant speed is so
important in being able to kill
anything. So, we have that here. And
next up is board wipe. Uh the best red
board wipe without a doubt is
blasphemous act. And this is not too
expensive. Now, it used to be a little
expensive, but now thanks to reprints,
this can I think this can be bought
fairly cheaply and the effect is so
good. What's great about this is you can
usually pay one mana to cast this.
Usually when the board is worth wiping,
this is one mana and you will be the
first to rebuild because you're not
tapped out like with other board wipes.
So blasmos
and next up is fumigate because in our
deck we actually we pay a fair bit of
life and also we are aggro. We're kind
of aggro so we are beating people down
and we should expect back swing and
fumigate is the board wipe. You pay one
more mana than wrath of god but you gain
one life for each creature destroyed
this way. So you can easily gain up to
10 life and sometimes when someone is
playing for example tokens going wide
this can just bring you above 40 easily.
So this is one of my favorite board
wives that a lot of people don't play.
Removals and board wipes are done. And
next up is some of the good stuff. We'll
start with just random good stuff cards
that work well with our deck with our
commander. Aurelia the war leader. Now
first you will notice that it is three
power. So, this can be brought by
brought back by our commander and it is
six mana and the ability is ridiculous.
Sure, it might not trigger. It doesn't
trigger on the when you first bring it
back, but once you start attacking with
Aurelia, all of your combats are
doubled. And this is the kind of
finisher we need to close out games. We
need to kill three opponents. It's not
easy. Aurelia will help you get there.
Uh, this goes into this pile here. Next
up, Sister of the Undead. Another
the same stats as Aurelia. basically six
mana 3 four. So perfect for our
commander. And this is another card that
reanimates. So I should actually put it
in this pile. Yeah, the card that
reanimates and brings stuff back uh in
kind of a backup plan to our commander
but more aggressive because the creature
enters tapped and attacking. So yeah,
I'll put this in in this pile actually.
Next up is Kamisur Severina Rain. This
is from another collector commander deck
from the Warhammer set. And this has
great synergy with her deck because it's
aggressive. It gains it life and when
you attack with creatures, it can
Chamisar can drain our opponents. And at
the same time, it's a sack outlet. We do
need some sack outlets. We we barely
have any, but sack outlets can be super
useful just because if you want to
re-trigger some of the ETB abilities,
you want to reuse some creatures, you
can sacrifice them to get value and then
bring them back with our commander. So,
this fits pretty well. Next up, Disciple
of Bolas. Yeah, another kind of sack
outlet. Also reusable if you can kill
this. Uh, what's great about this is you
can sacrifice any creature. We have some
pretty large creatures, right? We
sacrifice them, we convert them into
card and life, and if we need it again,
we can just bring it back, bring this
back with our commander later on. So
again, a much needed effect. Card draw,
life gain, and sack outlet all in one.
Next up is a well, two protection
spells. But one of them is a finisher.
The first protection spell is flawless
maneuver. Uh yeah, a free protection
spell is invaluable just because in our
decks uh in our deck, we want to tap out
because we are aggressive. We are
playing proactively. But when we do
that, we can get blown out by just a
simple board wipe. But with this, we can
actually blow our opponents out. If
they're holding their board wipe, just
waiting uh thinking that it will resolve
and they will survive. you cast this and
the next turn you do something like
Aurelia and they're just dead and you
can catch them by surprise and that's
how aggressive decks win games actually.
So, and uh here this goes here and I
stop Achrome as well. This is I believe
the most expensive card in this pile.
It's about $15.
Uh but this is just so powerful, so
ridiculously powerful. Uh, it's a
protection spell, but when used
proactively, giving your creatures
protection from all colors, flying,
double strike, lifelink,
this card by itself would will win any
race. Yeah, there once you resolve this,
you will not lose a race unless your
opponent has one of these two. Um, yeah,
not much to say. A beautiful finisher.
So yeah, we have a deck
and 100 cards pretty well balanced,
synergistic, and I think you can again
take this to a bracket three table and
do pretty well. So this is our opening
and upgrade guide to our revival trans
commander deck from Final Fantasy. This
deck is looks really fun. I look forward
to playing it. And I I will do the same
for the other three decks. I have them
here. I'll show you real quick. Uh this
is the Oops. This is the cloud deck.
What's it called? Limit Break. Limit
Break. And we have Whoops.
Um, Science and Spellcraft.
And lastly,
Counter Blitz.
So, we'll do videos for these. And if
you like this video, please subscribe
and like to not miss future videos. And
if you have any suggestions, please make
a comment. Thank you. I'll see you soon.